[Musique]
madame monsieur bonjour c'est une
tempête d'une rare violence la plus
forte depuis 50 ans qui a frappé la
partie nord du pays cette nuit mais
aussi paris et l'île de france pour les
pour l'instant il est très difficile
d'établir un bilan
il aurait déjà huit morts en france
peut-être plus et de nombreux blessés
dont plusieurs grièvement
les numéros d'urgence des pompiers de
paris sont indisponibles pour cause de
tempête
le standard de france télécom ayant été
endommagée le trafic aérien a été
interrompu sur les aéroports d'orly et
de roissy des tournées vers lyon et
bruxelles le trafic ferroviaire demeure
également très perturbé dans la région
parisienne les vents avoisiner 150
km/heure et certains quartiers de paris
offrait ce matin un spectacle de
désolation comme ont pu le constater
olivier caroff effet ni au vernis après
une nuit très agitée des pompiers
totalement débordées
ce matin dans paris qu'on les appelle
partout à la fois sur les toits ou des
cheminées se sont écroulés dans les rues
encombrées d'obstacles les plus divers
arbres feux de signalisation panneaux
publicitaires ou echaffaudages par
endroits à la tempête a tout arraché ce
cinéma a vu sa façade entièrement
démantibulé c'est en normandie hier et
c'était comme ça
donc je m'attendais en entendant vent
souffle et ce matin je m'attendais à
voir le match n'a pas quand même à paris
c'est avec les murs je pensais serait un
petit peu plus un peu plus haut quand
même des débris comme ceux-ci projetée
par le vent ou grièvement blessé trois
personnes à paris témoin de la violence
de la tempête l'enseigne du lido projeté
à plusieurs mètres du cabaret par
endroits les rafales de vent août
atteint les 150 km/heure sur les champs
elysées les roues géantes installées
pour l'an 2000 ont tenu le coup une
chance à souffler terrible ça souffle
est terrible et les arbres qui sont
tombés ça des barrières dans tous les
sens pouvait rien faire tant soir il
fallait attendre que tout se calme pour
pouvoir faire quelque chose sur la
pelouse de relier un festival
international du cirque devait ouvrir
dans deux jours il ne reste pas grand
chose mais on s'active déjà pour sauver
le matériel escape est ce qui me
réconforte c'est qui a pas de blessés
c'est que évidemment s'il ya du matériel
qui tombe sur la tête des mêmes des
employés ou tout ça on n'a rien donc
merci mon dieu
tant qu'il ya pas mort d'homme le reste
c'est une question de courage et on en a
plein des dégâts aussi dans les
aéroports à orly-ouest l'écoulement de
ces plaques de tôle a nécessité l'arrêt
de toute activité roissy a également dû
fermer dans la plupart des gares
parisiennes
on attend que les voix soient débloqués
pour reprendre le trafic en dehors de
paris
le bilan est déjà lourd huit morts
face à cette tempête que certains
spécialistes considèrent déjà comme la
tempête du siècle
les pompiers demandent surtout à ce
qu'on ne les appelle pas pour des dégâts
matériels
leur ligne 18 et le 112 sont
actuellement saturés
nos envoyés spéciaux en
charente-maritime olivier galzi nathalie
gallet ont eu du mal à trouver les
sauveteurs en uniforme en revanche
l'éleveur ils ont parfois été très
surpris
la tempête a laissé derrière elle des
images insolites des situations qui
raconte à elle seule la violence de
l'événement et l'impuissance des sommes
ici dans l'estuaire de la gironde
ce cargo poser comme une feuille bouche
l'entrée d'un port ce soir les habitants
de cette ferme repartiront en barque ils
ne dormiront pas chez eux ils sont
plusieurs centaines
dans cette situation laurent lui n'a pas
voulu quitter sa ferme mais il est isolé
presque coupée du reste du monde depuis
deux jours
la tempête n'a laissé ici que désolation
on fait ce qu'on peut on essaie dans la
journée de nettoyage qu'après dès que la
nuit tombe il peut rien à faire pas tant
et puis voilà vous n'avez pas d'eau pas
d'électricité
ainsi de leur apporter de l'eau potable
les pompiers puis dormir ça fait de
nuire un beau tellement envie de dormir
et si les pompiers distribuent de l'eau
l'armée elle prête son matériel les
hommes du 6e régiment du génie sont à
pied d'oeuvre depuis aujourd'hui
aulas ici on a engagé un moyen
polyvalent de juni mpg et on fait
l'ouverture vers un rétablissement dax
en fait le but là c'est quoi ça libérer
les lignes cdd idéal libérer les lignes
pour l'edf qui doit rétablir le courant
au plus vite
et ensuite
rétablir les axes pour les personnes
cinq engins comme celui-ci et 17 hommes
en tout pour le département entier mes
moyens mis en oeuvre par est cependant
bien faire demain d'autres renforts
militaires sont attendus
ils devront livrer la bataille de l'eau
et de l'électricité dans les zones les
plus isolées dans de nombreux endroits
du département l'hélicoptère reste le
meilleur moyen d'accéder aux zones
sinistrées
et justement parce qu'il ya plusieurs
endroits comme celui-ci coupé du monde
il est difficile à l'heure actuelle de
mesurer l'ampleur exacte des dégâts cela
prendra plusieurs jours plusieurs jours
pendant lesquels nombre d'habitants de
charente-maritime seront privés d'eau et
d'électricité dans l'île de france les
dégâts sont très importants notamment
dans l'oise val d'oise les yvelines
mais c'est à versailles que la tempête
semble avoir fait le plus de ravages
dans le parc du château
plus de 4000 arbres ont été déracinés la
toiture a été endommagée
florent muller et maryse richard le parc
du roi-soleil saccagé par les vents en
deux heures près de 4000 arbres
centenaires se sont inclinés devant les
bourrasques de 120 kilomètres heure
aujourd'hui vers ça y ressemble un
château de cartes certaines fenêtres ont
volé en éclats et les échafaudages
menace de s'écrouler devant ce désastre
les déesses de pierre en sont réduites à
jouer les charpentiers de fortune selon
un premier état des lieux la tempête a
été plus violente encore que celle de
1990 qui avait déjà coûté des millions
au château il cela pourrait s'aggraver
comme il ya des trous un peu partout
dans les toitures s'il a pu arrive a
reconnu le temps de vaches et de ferveur
on aura des dégâts dressage actuellement
tout le personnel est en train d'essayer
de boucher de colmater
très vite jusqu'à nouvel ordre le
château est fermée au public car la
forêt particulièrement dangereux à
versailles un homme a été tué par la
chute d'un arbre et de nombreuses routes
ont été éventrés mais les arbres ne sont
pas seuls en cause rue des chantiers on
a frôlé la catastrophe
une grue d'une trentaine de mètres s'est
écrasé sur un bâtiment en construction
les vents l'ont arraché de sa base et
celle ci est venu s'échouer dans le
jardin de la résidence voisine
tout s'est joué à quelques millimètres
pour les propriétaires de l'appartement
du dernier étage un peu secoué c'était
sais pas je pense j'ai jamais entendu de
bombes mais pour moi c'était un peu
comme une bombe ou quoi c'était une
énorme bombe qui tombait sur eux à côté
de notre immeuble parce que finalement
nous on était encore vivant oui mais les
morceaux de grue à côté oui vous êtes
coincé entre les deux c'est perdre wade
pour moi je me suis rendu compte que je
devais être miraculé toute la matinée
françoise et son mari ont tenté de
joindre un couvreur
en vain il faudra se faire au goutte à
goutte du plafond tendu et pour la
fenêtre on se contentera quelques jours
d'un carton personnes dans l'immeuble ne
comprend pourquoi cette grille n'a pas
été démontés malgré l'avis de tempête
d'autant qu'à quelques mètres d'autres
menaces tout jeune qui tombait sur l'app
store mais je ne sens pas la patte avec
mes enfants je me sens pas de toi
vous allez faire je sais pas on verra
c'est pas facile de dormir et qu'on aura
presque pas trop loin des crues c'est
pas moi je trouve ça j'ai peur à la gare
de meudon là encore on est passé à
quelques mètres du drame un arbre a
transpercé la voix une pincée de
secondes avant le passage du train et de
ses voyageurs
mais bien souvent le choc a été
inévitable
en ce lendemain de fête beaucoup se sont
réveillés avec une triste surprise et ce
n'est pas forcément au père noël qu'il
faut en vouloir
ce soir un million et demi de foyers
sont toujours privés d'électricité selon
edf qui demande de ne pas toucher aux
lignes électriques tombés au sol
fait exceptionnel le plan orsec a été
déclenché dans quatre départements les
vosges la marne la haute-marne et la
meurthe et moselle
reportage dans l'est de la france avec
nos correspondants à strasbourg jérôme
soûlard et patrice thomas cher des
rafales à 160 kilomètres/heure avec une
telle force les toitures se soulève
comme des feuilles les antennes vacille
et les routes deviennent vite
impraticable dans cette tornade
deux personnes vont trouver la mort lui
noyer l'autre écrasé par la chute d'un
arbre sur sa voiture au nord de
strasbourg
la forêt de brumath est en partie
dévasté les axes de circulation sont
presque totalement bloqués c'est
d'ailleurs le premier travail des
pompiers
établir la sécurité sur les principaux
axes de communication ce qui était en
pleurs étaient chez nous c'était donc de
dégager les la chance et quand nous
aurons 30 maintenant et puis éviter
qu'il ya d'autres d'autres chutes
d'arbres sur éventuellement des voitures
qui passent à quelques kilomètres de là
ce sont des pylônes edf que le vent a
brisé tel de simples château de cartes
les lignes à haute tension sont tombés
sur l'autoroute de paris des centaines
d'automobilistes étaient encore bloqués
en fin d'après midi
on a vu les arbres tombés sur les
voitures
alors on fait dire va rentrer un peu de
chance ça fait plus de deux heures de
3h12 être bloqués ici à trois heures
c'est pas fini je pense pas à pas l'air
de bouger beaucoup plus de routes et
plus de train non plus depuis ce matin
l'ensemble du réseau sncf est
complètement paralysée pour les arrivées
tout est bloqué aucun train depuis 9h ce
matin ne rentre il ne peut quitter la
gare de strasbourg
conséquence les voyageurs bloqués
devront être relogées dans des wagons
couchettes car les prévisions météo
restent pessimistes
nous restons très vigilants pour la
soirée car
mais la météo nous annonce une reprise
du vent autour de 100 kilomètres heure
pour la fin de soirée
en alsace les dégâts de cette tempête
reste ce soir très important cent vingt
mille foyers sont d'ailleurs toujours
privés d'électricité reste que la
plupart des liaisons tgv entre paris et
la province sont annulés jusqu'à demain
le trafic aérien a été lui aussi
fortement perturbé d'une manière
générale les responsables de la sécurité
civile recommande à chacun de renoncer à
circuler que ce soit par air par train
ou en voiture
état des lieux avec thiriez il ne
partira pas il restera à quai la cause
la tempête voyageurs dépités tgv
immobilisé le trafic ferroviaire a connu
un dimanche exceptionnel aucun train au
départ et à l'arrivée sur paris excepté
paris lille paris rennes et paris nantes
aucun trafic en lorraine très grosses
perturbations à lyon et jusqu'à 19
heures en haute tarentaise
aucun tgv au départ de marseille et ce
jusqu'à lundi matin
mais le trafic devrait redevenir normale
dès demain matin excepté le sud-est un
numéro pour se renseigner
08 36 67 68 69 trafic de banlieue prévue
demain gare saint-lazare très perturbé 1
train sur 3 sur la ligne b et d du rer
ainsi que paris est et paris nord en ce
qui concerne les avions le trafic a été
rétabli à la mi-journée les aéroports de
roissy-charles-de-gaulle orly bâle
mulhouse et strasbourg ont été fermés de
longues heures et d'ailleurs bâle
mulhouse et strasbourg pourraient bien
refermer à orly huit avions de
différentes compagnies ont été
légèrement endommagés ainsi que
plusieurs structures et systèmes
informatiques secondaire selon edf
huit cent mille à un million et demi de
personnes serait ce soir encore privés
d'électricité régions les plus touchées
la bretagne la vendée l'ile-de-france
les vosges et le jura
edf recommande de ne jamais touché une
ligne électrique tombée à terre au
dessus d'un axe la rochelle colmar tout
le réseau routier a été touchée on ne
compte plus les arbres et les panneaux
arrachés ainsi que les routes à
circulation alternée l'autoroute a13 est
coupée à orgeval ainsi que la a14 vers
paris province l'a86 est coupée à
maisons alfort et l'on prévoit pour la
soirée de gros embouteillages en
direction de paris
dans la marne le moulin de valmy symbole
des luttes révolutionnaires n'a pas
résisté à la tempête dans tout le pays
en fait on ne compte plus les dégâts qui
sont extrêmement spectaculaires alors
qu'un nouvel avis de tempête est
annoncée pour ce soir la sécurité civile
recommande surtout de ne pas sortir
voyez ces images commentées par hervé
brusini quatre morts le calvados
dénombre aujourd'hui quatre victimes
jour même de noël ce fut une ferme qui
s'écoulait sous le coup d'une
mini-tornade une femme de 51 ans et un
homme de 39 décédé sous les décombres
une fillette de 4 ans est grièvement
blessé aujourd'hui un homme a glissé du
toit qu'ils tentaient de réparer une
femme a été tuée sous sa maison arrachés
par la tempête routes secondaires
bloqués cent dix mille foyers privés
d'électricité
et ce soir une partie du département qui
est sous les eaux
160 km/heure à colmar et dans le centre
de l'alsace autant dire que la région a
été soumise à rude épreuve deux blessés
graves sous le clocher de cette église
par miracle aucune victime sous celui
mais deux femmes ont trouvé la mort une
branche qui vient frapper une passante
et la noyade pour une autre surprise par
la montée des eaux
ici les rafales de vent se sont
engouffrés dans la barre d'immeuble cité
des pétrels alors brutalement vécu
l'angoissé d'une véritable tempête
cheminée ce bâtiment juste au-dessus
tomber s'envoler les voler les vitres
cassées et puis j'ai pas on a essayé de
mettre la table en travers la fenêtre
pour tenir les fenêtres qui touche
énormément
par précaution on a évacué les 150
personnes qui vivent là la bâtisse
montrait ses premières fissures et du
pouce de vitry-le-françois ont retrouvé
dans le gymnase du vieux port
les 350 passagers du train budapest
paris qui venait d'être stoppée à reims
la violence du vent a dévasté tout ce
qui ne pouvait résister aux 150 km heure
de cette même tornade submergé les
pompiers ont reçu plus de 3000 à peine
les 160 hommes sur place ne suffisait
pas à la préfecture une cellule de crise
tente de gérer la situation plus
d'électricité voies de communications
coupées et surtout un nouveau coup de
vent
qui s'annonce pour ce soir ce soir le
plan orsec a été déclenché dans quatre
départements les vosges la marne la
haute-marne et la meurthe et moselle
mais cette tempête cette tempête
exceptionnelle à d'abord touché l'ouest
de la france la bretagne et la normandie
où neuf personnes ont trouvé la mort
d'importants dégâts matériels sont
également à déplorer
des images impressionnantes commentée
par dominique dumas la normandie touché
de plein fouet par la tornade dans tous
les départements normands des dizaines
de toits ont été arrachés provoquant de
nombreux dégâts matériels
ce matin trois personnes ont été
blessées dans l'effondrement d'une
maison à colleville dans le calvados les
arbres par dizaines en tombant sur les
chaussées ont causé de nombreux
accidents faisant au moins une dizaine
de blessés
la circulation devrait être en partie
rétablie sur les grands axes mais les
problèmes demeurent sur les routes
secondaires
on déplore jusqu'à ce soir cinq victimes
deux hier dans le calvados
aujourd'hui un homme de 70 ans à
cricqueboeuf est une jeune femme a cool
20 une femme de 90 ans a également été
découverte ce soir sans vie dans les
décombres de sa maison de saint lô selon
les secteurs un foyer sur deux ou sur
trois étaient privés d'électricité en
fin d'après midi le trafic sncf devrait
reprendre demain lundi les plages
normandes elle aussi offre un aspect de
désolation la bretagne déjà éprouvée par
la marée noire paye également un lourd
tribut à la tempête
quatre morts dans un accident sur la
voie express rennes saint brieuc à cause
de la chute d'un arbre
des dizaines de toitures ont été
arrachées comme ici dans cette maison de
retraite de bégard dans les côtes
d'armor un département parmi les plus
touchés en bretagne
ce soir le gouvernement envoie trois
mille hommes pour aider les bretons
certaines équipes qui devaient se rendre
dans le grand ouest ont été bloqués à
cause de la tempête vous pouvez plus
dégarnir certains départements nous
devons faire face sur beaucoup de fronts
à la fois la tempête et la pollution
maritime
un nouveau coup de vent est prévu pour
cette nuit ce qui risque encore
d'aggraver la situation
de nombreuses routes étant coupées par
les inondations de ces dernières 24
heures européens n'ont pas été épargné
par le mauvais temps
dix morts en allemagne 8 en suisse
julien colombani
après la france la tempête a continué sa
course folle vers le centre de l'europe
c'est l'allemagne qui a été la plus
touchée dix personnes ont été tuées dans
le sud ouest du pays
on compte les blessés par dizaines les
victimes ont pour la plupart été écrasé
par la chute des arbres déracinés car là
aussi la violence de la tempête a tout
arraché les grues n'ont pas résisté aux
vents dépassant les 100 kilomètres heure
des pointes à 213 ont même été
enregistrés en forêt noire
le trafic a été partiellement stoppé des
dizaines de routes et d'autoroutes sont
restés bloqués pendant des heures 30
lignes de chemin de fer ont été coupées
et aucun avion n'a décollé de munich et
de stuttgart aujourd'hui de l'autre côté
de la frontière en suisse le bilan est
lui aussi très lourd huit morts rarement
le lac léman n'a pris de telle allure
d'océan une tempête digne des côtes
atlantiques a causé sur ses berges des
millions de francs de dégâts
même scénario qu'en france et en
allemagne peu de choses on résister à la
bourrasque une cabine de téléphérique
c'est même décroché faisant un mort et
deux blessés graves dans sa trajectoire
la tempête a atteint plusieurs autres
pays de l'europe du nord-ouest
les premiers à l'aube l'irlande et la
grande-bretagne ou cinq morts sont à
déplorer et la belgique où la flandre a
subi de graves inondations
en plus des dégâts causés par le vent
l'eau et la boue a déferlé dans les
maisons
cette tempête est la plus forte qu ait
connu l'europe depuis dix ans à cette
époque elle avait fait 200 victimes
jacques chirac a exprimé ses
condoléances aux familles des victimes
il a fait part de son émotion après les
conséquences dramatiques de la tempête
au nord de la loire tous les
départements en ont subi les effets le
point avec stéphanie perez des toitures
effondrées des voitures et endommagé des
arbres arrachés
partout le même spectacle de désolation
et de nombreuses victimes
ici à argenteuil deux personnes sont
mortes dans leur appartement
après la chute de la cheminée de leur
immeuble en tout 27 personnes au moins
ont trouvé la mort cette nuit et ce
matin en bretagne en normandie en ile de
france et dans le nord-est du pays le
plus souvent à cause de chutes d'arbres
on compte également deux disparus et des
dizaines de blessés c'est une tempête
que météo-france qualifient d'historique
un vie
itab l'ouragan s'est abattu sur le nord
du pays c'est d'abord la bretagne qui a
été touchée vers 4 heures du matin puis
toute l'île de france
enfin l'est du pays avec des vents d'une
violence inouïe qui ont atteint jusqu'à
172 kilomètres heure à orly pour paris
on a relevé des valeurs devant qu'on
n'avait jamais vu depuis 50 ans ces
valeurs devant sont à peu près
comparable à celle qui a eu en octobre
87 dans l'ouragan qui avait touché la
bretagne et la normandie avec des
rafales de 60 60 ou 160 km h dans
l'intérieur des terres
ce qui est tout à fait exceptionnel pour
pour la france à l'heure actuelle entre
800 mille et un million et demi de
foyers sont toujours privés
d'électricité dans 70 départements
plus de trois mille techniciens edf
travaille d'arrache-pied le plan orsec a
été déclenché dans quatre départements
de l'est ainsi que le plan blanc en
meurthe-et-moselle qui réquisitionne les
personnels hospitaliers pour faire face
aux urgences
enfin à noter que le trafic sncf reste
très perturbé ce soir au nord d'une
ligne nantes nancy particulièrement
touché la région parisienne où les
dégâts sur la ligne sont très importants
de nombreux tgv en direction de la
capitale sont supprimés la tempête qui a
balayé le nord de la france ce week-end
a tué 39 personnes et fait 1 disparus
selon un dernier bilan communiqué par la
sécurité civile
ce soir encore des dizaines de milliers
de foyers sont privés d'électricité
d'eau et de téléphone
partout on tente de réparer au plus vite
les dégâts
le point tout de suite avec dominique
dumas d arbre arraché des toitures
effondrées des voitures éventrée c'est
le bilan matériel de cette tornade
historique
il faut maintenant revivre normalement
comme ici dans le calvados
difficile quand on sait qu'en dehors du
courant et du téléphone coupé les
canalisations d'eau sont hors d'usagé
dans ce département il est d'ailleurs
déconseillé de boire l'eau du robinet
mais c'est le bilan humain le plus
dramatique de son passage pendant
quelques heures de l'ouest vers l'est de
l'europe
au moins trente et une personnes ont
péri dans l'ensemble de ces départements
figurant sur la carte avec notamment
cinq victimes
en ille et vilaine pour l'île de france
sept personnes sont mortes et il suffit
de voir les arbres déracinés et les
échafaudages effondré pour imaginer la
force des rafales dans l'est
cinq départements ont déclenché le plan
seck pour les cinq régions du grand est
on déplore 15 morts et 390 blessé
plusieurs personnes âgées ont péri
c'est donc maintenant la solidarité
envers les plus faibles qui doit jouer
comme ici en alsace dans cette résidence
pour retraités qu'il aura fallu évacuer
en toute hâte vers haguenau
c'est très dur un bon c'est sûr les gens
ne sont pas
préparer vraiment qu'est ce que vous
voulez des personnes âgées c'est pas
évident enfin pour un agriculteur de
d'ohnenheim la perte est importante son
étable s'est effondrée ces 48 vaches
étaient prises au piège à un moment
donné on voyait le tout le toit qui
commençait à soulever qui se remettait
en classe et vers les midis 12h10 tout
s'est écroulé d'un seul coup il y avait
un nuage de poussière et non si les
principales liaisons comme ici dans les
vosges ont pu être rétablie aujourd'hui
il faudra rester vigilant car des routes
secondaires sont toujours barrées par
des arbres que ce soit l'alsace où les
autres régions touchées par la tempête
le bilan matériel sera très longue le
vent mais aussi les pluies qui ont
accompagné la tempête ont largement
inondé vie des villages et bien sûr et
rivières sont en crue
plusieurs communes du pays de caulnes
disposent plus d'eau potable
ce film est lé christian euros et est
aujourd'hui en seine maritime de ce côté
ci de la route
la mère a l'air presque paisible rien ne
trahit la détresse de la région 6e 17
bus qui les versent depuis 24 heures son
torrent de boue à deux mètres de là ces
cabanons de vacances se vantait naguère
d'avoir les pieds dans l'eau ils ont
aujourd'hui peu fière allure
contre nous ce sont les grosses marées
lors du ce du fait que les grosses
maréval abusa pains des vies qu'on
dirait jeu comme d'habitude donc là
forcément balocchi accus et ici derrière
nous ba du mal à partir puisque
justement le phénomène des grosses marc
ayrault tiens justement ce débit on
venait dépendre le fumier dans ce
potager de la région de dieppe
peine perdue les propriétaires sont en
vacances alors en leur absence
la solidarité s'organise comme il était
pas là toute la famille est venue pour
lui c'est cuit tous les voisins sont
venus à quelques dizaines de kilomètres
de là sur la côte saint valery en caux
reste l'une des communes les plus
touchées le long de l'avenue carnot
toutes les familles ont dû être relogées
elle découvrait ce matin l'ampleur des
dégâts souvenirs détrempée que l'on n'a
pas encore le coeur de jeter
vous avez prévu de rentrer chez vous
quand bart prend l'ascendant
c'est pourquoi aussi falloir voir
l'appartement là plus rien n'y a pas
écrit cité réchauffage de yeah yeah
fonctionnent les meubles ce soir et plus
de télé les poiriers les habitants d'ici
le savez un jour ou l'autre le village
serait inondé mais en ce lendemain de
noël préparé ou pas on a du mal à se
faire une raison
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir 135 mille
foyers sont donc toujours en champagne
ardenne ce soir privés d'électricité
c'est l'une des principales conséquences
de la tempête qui a balayé la région
dans la journée d'hier
depuis maintenant trente six heures des
dizaines de milliers d'habitants vivent
sans lumière et parfois sans chauffage à
l'image vous allez voir des
pensionnaires de cette maison de
retraite dans la marne à avenay val d'or
voilà plus de trente heures que les
pensionnaires de la maison de retraite
sont privés d'électricité
trente heures sans chauffage sans eau
chaude sans ascenseur sans lumière
emmitouflés des pieds à la tête
il s'agit de tenir le coup pour le
personnel aussi les personnels qui
servent eux le repas sont obligés de
tout faire par les escaliers c'est à
dire qu'il me prenne nos chariots il
laisse en bas et il bouge comme sera de
même pour les toilettes pour les
infirmières faire les soins c'est
difficile aussi parce qu'on n'avait pas
d'eau chaude ou très peu donc il fallait
faire ça me fait rater semble pas usé
l'eau chaude comme dans le temps je
suppose que c'était une cinquante ans et
et puis le miracle
la préfecture vient de faire livrer un
groupe électrogène à l'électricien est
réquisitionnée pour installer
provisoirement du show page c'est la
priorité
j'aime faire l'examen des puissances qui
a besoin est pour l'instant le
meilleure solution à prendre dans
l'immédiat c'est d'alimenter la
chaufferie je vais la mesurer et si on
peut faire à mesure on pourra monter en
puissance pour les soixante neuf
pensionnaires l'arrivée du chauffage est
accueilli comme une excellente nouvelle
même si le groupe électrogène est
insuffisant pour alimenter tout le
bâtiment
c'est pas grave la télé il la
regarderont plus tard mais voilà il
chauffage arrive
[Musique]
si la tour eiffel a résisté à la tempête
d'hier ce n'est pas le cas des trois
mille cinq cents arbres endommagés ou
déracinés dans les jardins comme ici au
champ de mars dans les cimetières et le
long des rues toute la journée
2500 employés des services municipaux
ont dégagé des centaines d'arbres pour
rétablir la circulation
la priorité a été donnée aux jardins du
trocadéro au champ-de-mars et aux champs
elysées en prévision des célébrations de
l'an 2000 mais les plus gros dégâts ont
été constatés dans les bois de boulogne
et de vincennes où 140 mille arbres ont
été endommagées soit près de la moitié
l'adjointe au maire de paris françoise
de panafieu n'hésite pas à parler d'un
désastre écologique
il faudra attendre trois ans pour
déblayer entièrement les bois et des
décennies pour reconstituer le
patrimoine vert par précaution car
désabre risque encore de s'effondrer
tous les jardins de la capitale ont été
fermées au public et dans les cimetières
seuls les inhumations ont été autorisés
les monuments historiques de la capitale
et de sa proche banlieue n'ont pas été
épargnés c'est le cas du château de
versailles mais aussi du panthéon dont
le dôme a particulièrement souffert des
dégâts également à notre dame ainsi qu'à
la sainte chapelle où un vitrail a été
brisée reportage de nathalie et terre et
laurent soit à première vue les dégâts
ne sont pas flagrants pourtant il suffit
de s'approcher du dôme du panthéon pour
comprendre que cette tempête la à défaut
de réveiller les morts a bel et bien
arraché une partie du toit de l'édifice
plus d'une dizaine de plaques de plomb
était soufflé est projeté à quelques 80
mètres à la ronde
chacune de ces plaques pèse environ 100
kilos et
au cours de cette tornade qui a eu lieu
hier matin
zen comme celle ci
sont tombés à la fois sur la voie
publique et dans le monument certaines
ont d'ailleurs transpercé la toiture
mais d'autres sont roulés un petit peu
comme des feuilles de papier à cigarette
par la force du vent
ces autres plaques devront également
être remplacée coût approximatif des
travaux 4 à 5 millions de francs
la sainte chapelle elle a eu de la
chance dans son malheur la chute d'un
clocheton a brisé un vitrail rien de
trop important le monument devrait
rouvrir ses portes dans les prochains
jours c'est incontestablement notre dame
qui a le plus souffert de la tempête
au total six pinacle sont tombés sur la
nef et la sacristie et d'énormes blocs
de pierres ont littéralement troué
plusieurs terrasses catherine trautmann
présente sur les lieux s'est engagé à
faciliter les démarches pour lancer les
travaux d'urgence entre autres dégager
les pierres qui menace à tout moment de
s'effondrer
l'état va faire responsabilité
propriétaire
les propriétaires des cathédrales donc
ces liquides va assurer la remise en
état puis ensuite la restauration qui
s'imposera en attendant c'est à la
caisse des monuments historiques
d'évaluer le coût des réparations
elles sont actuellement estimés à
quelques 200 millions de francs pour
l'ensemble de la france
alors bien sûr se poser la question sur
la force des ventes changera guère la
physionomie des paysages désormais
détruit
il n'empêche les questions viennent sur
les prévisions de météo france sur le
mélange d'ouragan de tornades constaté
de l'ouest à l'est de la france enquête
sur un phénomène météorologique complexe
avec agnès monteux laetitia legendre et
christophe laroque
une tempête d'une telle violence sur une
distance aussi grande en france
les météorologues n'avais encore jamais
vu ça ce qui frappe le plus les
scientifiques c'est que la force des
vents n'a pas diminué en s'enfonçant à
l'intérieur des terres bien au contraire
à 4 heures du matin et hier des rafales
de 184 kilomètres heure frappe l'île
d'ouessant 180 km/heure dans le calvados
173 km heure à orly en ile de france et
144 kilomètres heure a strasbourg les
plus à l'est
les ventes deviennent encore plus
violent de 100 kilomètres heure en
suisse et 213 km heure dans la forêt
noire en allemagne
cette dépression très creuse s'est
déplacé rapidement
elle s'apparente à un cyclone ce n'est
pas un cyclone tropical on est loin
d'être pic mais c'est ainsi qu'en dans
le sens qu'elle le sens de la
circulation générale des vents c'est
dans le sens contraire aux aiguilles
d'une manque
météo france avait été très précis sur
la trajectoire de ce cyclone mais
impossible de prévoir les mini
tourbillon à l'intérieur même de la
dépression qui ont localement accentuer
l'effet tempête nous avions sous-estimé
la force des vents un peu sous-estimé la
force des vents eh bien ça s'explique en
effet par ces phénomènes locaux qui
naissent et qui disparaissent dans une
période de temps extrêmement réduite
pour comprendre ces mini tourbillon il
faut remonter à 8000 mètres d'altitude
jusque dans la troupe oppose la des
vents violents de 400 km heure se serait
rabattu sur le sol un phénomène très
rare qui expliquerait l'intensité de
cette tempête en pleine terre
il ya donc ce soir un bilan de 69 morts
en france après deux jours de tempête la
seconde la nuit dernière a tué 24
personnes dont 12 dans le seul
département de la charente-maritime nous
commençons donc par celui ci avec la
rochelle où la ville dès hier soir a été
carrément mise ko par les vents les
pluies à l'intérieur des terres comme
dans les ports au petit matin c'était un
désastre
nos envoyés spéciaux christophe va
l'embrasser à l'un des grands nous le
racontent les voiliers magnifique du
port des minimes
relégué au rang de vulgaire branche
morte cette nuit la tempête les
harrachis à leur splendeur et les a
jetés là agonise
je suis consterné je vois ce matin je me
suis promené parquet c'est c'est
terrible et quand je vois ce désastre à
côté c'est c'est dantesque de voir ça
s'est jamais vu ça jamais je suis une
peur cette nuit incroyable j'habite aux
minimes se demander ce qu'elle y arriver
car à la rochelle on s'attendait à une
tempête mais certainement pas celle ci
tellement violente des rafales à plus de
160 km heure inimaginable
j'étais chez des amis dans la rochelle
il ya un gros arbre énorme qui est déjà
tombé sur la maison
on est venu voir là mais on s'est fait
on est tombé d'une tornade in énorme
n'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie
ça fait 20 ans je fais du bateau j'avais
vu ça le vent nous a poussés dans les
rues de la rochelle au pas de
gymnastique on pouvait pas s'arrêter
ateliers de s'accrocher après les murs
jamais dans ses rues le vent n'a hurlé
si fort si dur les avenues illuminé
quand l'électricité capricieuse le
permet ce fonds piégeuse dangereuse le
vent est là et le vieux port a du mal à
contenir la menace sur les routes de
campagne tout proche le danger vient des
arbres des dizaines des centaines
déracinés par d'irrésistibles rafale
trop d'appels
les secours sont submergés alors on se
débrouille tout seul pour passer malgré
les risques comment vous allez faire
raccrocher la saga l'armé accrochée au
camion est tiré avait pas de moi thème
de matériel spécialisé
ah bah non c'est bon là il nomma la
rochelle s'est éveillée meurtri ce matin
partout les séquelles de la force
dévastatrice du vent voici tout ce qu'il
reste des barrages flottants polmar
installé la semaine dernière pour
protéger le port du fioul de l'erika
dans toute la ville
les dégâts sont spectaculaires et il
faudra encore plusieurs jours pour en
mesurer la véritable ampleur
alors qu'un million trois cent mille
foyers je vous le disais restent privés
d'électricité dans l'est le centre
l'ouest et le sud ouest le bilan des
deux tempêtes qui ont frappé la france
s'est encore alourdi 74 personnes ont
péri ces trois derniers jours jacques
chirac se rendra dans la haute vienne
demain auprès des populations sinistrées
l'état de catastrophe naturelle a été
déclaré aujourd'hui pour une soixantaine
de départements
le point avec sophie rolland un
gigantesque meccano aérien dans le ciel
de l'alsace c'est hélicoptère est venue
de pau pour changer un pylône d'une
ligne haute tension
une mobilisation à l'image de ce qui se
passe un peu partout en france une
mobilisation qui a payé près de six cent
mille foyers ont retrouvé la lumière
aujourd'hui mais un million trois cent
mille ans sont toujours privés ce soir
notamment dans le sud-ouest le centre et
l'ouest selon jean pierre chevènement
retour à la normale s'annonce difficile
avant la fin de la semaine
[Musique]
hors des zones d'ombré des zones qui
resteront plongée dans l'obscurité parce
que le raccordement au réseau électrique
n'aura pas pu être fait
dans quelles proportions je ne peux pas
le dire conséquence des coupures
d'électricité et un million d'abonnés
sont toujours privés de téléphone
la situation pourrait même se dégrader
dès demain dans les petites villes et
les zones isolées du sud de la france
là les abonnés dépendent de petits
centraux relayé par de simples batterie
qui ont une autonomie limitée ces petits
centraux sont sécurisés par des
batteries comme ça des grosses batteries
qui leur donne une autonomie de environ
deux jours
malheureusement si le courant électrique
ne revient pas à vous deux jours ces
batteries sont vides le central s'arrête
qui peut expliquer que une zone qui
étaient en bon fonctionnement d'un seul
coup devient cette fois-ci hors service
autre problème la pénurie d'eau potable
faute d'électricité pour actionner les
pompes les châteaux d'eau vides ne
peuvent renouveler leur stock principale
région touchée l'aquitaine le limousin
et le poitou charentes
conséquence certains préfets ont décidé
de rationner l'eau minérale
les distributeurs d'eau et mobilisent
leurs groupes électrogènes
[Applaudissements]
actuellement nous essayons d'acheminer
des groupes électrogènes vers la
dordogne et vers le sud de la gironde à
partir d'autres régions où le manque
d'eau
n'est pas du tout
réalité outre le manque d'eau potable
certaines régions doivent faire face à
d'importantes inondations notamment dans
l'ouest de la france et ce soir les
niveaux de la sarthe et de la loire ne
cesse d'augmenter
c'était au lendemain de noël il y a
pratiquement un an la france était
balayée par la tempête du siècle
de mémoire d'homme jamais catastrophe
naturelle d'une telle ampleur ne s'était
abattue sur le pays
88 morts et des dizaines de milliards de
francs de dégâts à villemoisson dans
l'essonne silva le kent et stéphane
taponier ont retrouvé une famille est
sinistré par l'ouragan
une famille qui prépare noël après avoir
passé une année particulièrement
difficile
l'immeuble est à ciel ouvert le jour de
la tempête le toit de leur appartement
s'est envolé ça c'était le la toiture
qui était au sol
ah le lendemain matin un an après les
images sont encore présentes
la famille le roux en garde un souvenir
douloureux
7h15 on a entendu un fracas des verts se
sont brisées dans la vitrine
l'immeuble a tremblé
la grosse tête on a cru que l'immeuble
s'effondre et ça on a cru que notre
dernière heure était arrivée au quai est
la seule solution c'était de se
rapprocher les uns des autres donc on
sait tous on s'est tous rassemblés après
la tempête lieu rouen vendu leur
appartement pour acheter ce pavillon
même si les proches ont aidé ainsi que
la fondation de france qui leur a versé
15 mille francs l'année a été difficile
toutes les démarches administratives qui
te
les conséquences que ça eu sur la vie de
tous les jours les conséquences
familiales les conséquences
professionnelles
on ne fait que cette année passée à une
vitesse phénoménale
aujourd'hui ils préparent leur réveillon
avec un peu plus de sérénité
un premier réveillon après la tempête
qui se fera dans l'intimité a prévu de
passer tous les quatre ensemble ce qu'on
a besoin d'être un peu de se réunir et
de vivre un après noël sera avec les
enfants est venu pour leur joie qui joue
avec et qui en profite et c'est vrai que
c'est important
un an après ce réveillon symbolise une
étape même si les stigmates de la
tempête ne sont pas oubliés ça sera pas
le les mauvais souvenirs même peut-être
un nouveau départ
pour passer sur 7
sur cette catastrophe le 26 décembre la
tempête lothar ravagé effectivement la
france d'ouest en est sylvain lequesne
retrace son parcours la tempête arrive
par le nord de la bretagne
il est deux heures du matin des vents
d'une violence exceptionnelle
s'engouffre sur le pays les habitants du
calvados font partie des premières
victimes leur région ce matin là
ressemble à un champ de bataille
les vents soufflaient à plus de 170 km à
saint pierre sur dives la vie les
sinistrés à 80% des dizaines de tonnes
de béton de pierre et de bois se sont
envolés dévié écrasé une femme est tuée
ici par la chute de ses cheminées au
total 18 personnes vont trouver la mort
dans le nord ouest dans toutes les
casernes
les pompiers sont débordés à rouen la
cathédrale est touché en plein coeur un
clocheton a crevé la voûte et s'est
écrasée 28 mètres plus bas
on a l'impression de retrouver des
images de 44 lors de haut rang devant la
cathédrale sous l'effet de la pluie du
vent ou plusieurs dizaines de cours
d'eau sortent de leur lit à fécamp cette
rue est en veille par une coulée de boue
sans précédent m vers 7 heures du matin
la tempête arrive sur l'île de france
les vents n'ont pas faibli en pénétrant
à l'intérieur des terres 216 km heure au
sommet de la tour eiffel baril est sens
dessus dessous les colonnes morris sont
à terre et plusieurs centaines d'arbres
centenaires se sont écroulés pendant les
couches et les personnes âgées qui sont
là depuis 40 ans un n'ont jamais connu
ça et j'en tremble encore
à paris près de 60% des toits sont
endommagés les pompiers ici aussi sont
submergés les bois de boulogne et de
vincennes ne sont plus que des champs de
ruines
cent quarante mille arbres sont balayées
[Musique]
vers 9 heures la tempête se déplace vers
l'est
reims strasbourg nancy et metz sont
touchés de plein fouet une seule
préoccupation se mettre à l'abri le plus
rapidement possible comme ailleurs le
travail de plusieurs générations
d'agriculteurs s'est envolé dans la
région de troyes
les 6000 mètres carrés de cette serre
sont balayés en quelques minutes des
centaines de pylônes sont réduits à
l'état de ferraille
ce jour là plus de deux millions de
personnes seront privées d'électricité
80% des routes secondaires sont coupées
au nord de la loire
ce 26 décembre la france se réveille
sous le choc ce jour-là 53 personnes
trouveront la mort et les esprits
resteront marqués à jamais
[Musique]